So how are we going to
solve the aperture problem?
Well, look,
the basic idea is the same as before,
we have to impose some sort of
constraints, but this time we're
going to impose some local constraints
to get more equations per pixel.
So for example, We talked about
maybe we'll assume that locally
right around this point,
the motion field is very smooth.
In fact how smooth do we want to assume?
How bout we assume that it's
actually the same value.
That is over a window,
we're going to assume that u v
is the same value everywhere.
So if we were using, let's say a five
by five window, so there's 25 pixels,
if we were assuming that there
was one u v for all of these,
the uv for, let's say, the center pixel.
That would give us 25
equations per pixel.
And here they are so,
what we've got here is, here's our u and
v that we're assuming is
the u v of some center pixel.
And here we have 25 rows
of the derivative on x and
the derivative in y at
each of those 25 points.
And th, this, these are the gradients,
dotted with u v equals the negative,
and here is the temporal derivatives
at each of those points.
So I can write that as a d equals b,
where d is this
displacement vector u v and
b is just this 25 by 1 vector,
that is essentially the negative
of all the temporal derivatives.
Okay, so
we have this equation a d equals b and
it's got 25 equations and two unknowns.
All right, well, so
that's a little bit of a problem.
How do we solve a system when we
have more equations than unknowns?
Well We do our standard
least square solution.
When we have an equation like this,
we say,
well, we're going to minimize
the square difference, okay.
And they way you do that is by using
the standard pseudo uh,inverse method.
So we multiply a by a transpose.
And since a is 25 by 2,
a trans-flows is 2 by 25, so
a transpose is just a 2 by 2 and d is
a 2 by 1, and a transpose b is a 2 by 1,
and we end up with this
equation right here, okay?
And these have the terms written out.
And these sums are summed over
whatever the window is it
that you're summing over.
So it's five by five would be over
all those 25 pixels and over here,
you just have the product of the,
the sum of the product of the,
image gradient and
times the temporal gradient.
This is our, what we have to solve,
and by the way,
this technique was first profos,
proposed by Luke Scigotti way back in
the dark ages of computer vision, 1981,
which is not quite the dark, dark age.
It was the dawning of it.
The dark ages were in the 60s.
All right, we just did that.
We can solve our squares and
come up with a solution, but
let's understand exactly what
solving this means, okay.
So you remember the aperture problem,
right?
And so here it's drawn out.
That the idea is if I have
a gradient in some direction, and so
this is my little gradient there.
Right?
So
that any u v that's along this
line would be an acceptable u v.
That is any u v whose component in
the direction of the gradient would be
acceptable.
And that's what this says.
That there's a single equation for that.
And that's the equation
of a line in uv space.